[Music]
an online-dating news hmm submit if I
twist your wrist when you jack off like
this yeah that's it Oh twister always
ready
you learn how to jerk oh yeah well thank
my ex-boyfriend before and and so my pop
can you do it wrong like this like
pulling it off yeah and then my my first
boyfriend he's like okay let me just
show you like it's like this like see
and then I was like oh there's skin
moves like whoa my my wrist is so much
bigger than your dick I wish I was I
wish your dick was my wrist
this is so cool better just tell your
lettering yeah always
mm-hm I'm coping it was my high school
boyfriend yeah [ __ ] that guy like him
all right but all right all right all
right you're right you're right you're
right that's it he's nice we don't talk
to that guy we don't talk about him
either
yeah [ __ ] it what is he what if this is
what kind of weight [ __ ] guy
we were Nick and Nikki oh so cute when I
was 13 I was jealous of my girlfriend at
the Times Elementary ex-boyfriend
because she told me about him then I was
like oh he had you first you loved him
first
yeah I was pissed because my ex was in
love with Brandon Boyd from Incubus and
so I was like oh get so upset I was like
I know you still love him
I knew me now oh my god I would bully
the [ __ ] out of that guy I was like 15
yeah there's a little too old yeah you
made up drama in your head yeah oh boy
it is pretty [ __ ] hot it's hard to
resist
it's weird I went with physically the
spirituali Geoff Joshi you'd be worried
no cuz she'd never have a chance that's
how the truth I think you heard nah
could definitely okay he's way yeah I
see her right now she has no shot with
Brendan boy and I say that with all he's
all down your ideas around her still no
I say that with all respect he's taking
that ex-girlfriend [ __ ] out on me right
yeah no no shot jets no it's actually
funny is that I ended up going to New
York Film Academy with his little
brother who looked identical don't know
did you take it out on him no he was so
good that I just got over everything
that's the water is just the coolest guy
totally over it now I'm really over it
yeah that's the worse when you have a
rival started dating Brandon Boyd yeah
basically all right there we go here's
how the slide into the DMS without being
a creep yeah Joe knows how yeah that's
how your relationship approach you want
a flooded you know no pellicer approach
well you're the [ __ ] creep right now
is your wait what is that what you say
hey Becca tell us from the beginning
what happened I feel like I'm told this
right before but um he just well I think
I was following him cuz I had seen a few
JK news or JK films get Maddie Maddie
and Sophie no I don't maybe I don't
think so I don't remember anyways
so I've seen a few JK films skits and so
I was just like started falling all the
crew or whatever and button I commented
probably on his page whatever whatever
and then he starts DMing me what about
Maddie he was like is that a Shiba and I
was just like no it's not and then he
just kept the conversation going and you
kept the conversation going
you've got the conversation go
it's not flirting I wasn't even flirty I
was just talking about dogs what that's
a really cute dog
oh you know what else is cute this [ __ ]
and then BOOM people right over and then
she said why don't you come over for
some barbecue and said that was a long
time later but you haven't forgotten
that because that's pretty tight weeks
later I'm talking and we were talking
every single day from the day that he
messaged me we talked every day all day
long huge we had a connection
no you're not texting me and you
wouldn't stop responding you were always
there and if I may be and then you sent
that one fateful text let's get separate
rooms talking about how he's creeped
itself looks like let's get separate
rooms yeah that's so funny now I just
picked you guys on the couch and they're
talking about how you guys first started
[Music]
he's like all the community necks
I gotta still do some more work cuz you
know Jake a new setup and I'm like well
I gotta get up at 6:00 a.m. so I'll see
you later MA and then we just I just go
straight to sleep I don't even say that
I need my room I call him from the
bedroom because right there anyway yeah
like after I call him he'll be like okay
I'm gonna come up
sometimes if I could tell that she's
like basically Zonk already yeah I just
I just say good night because she is a
dead body but then you go to sleep in
the same bed later yeah yeah yeah always
yeah but I like I like to write late
yeah sometimes he's going to bed when
I'm waking up sometimes yeah yeah yeah
cuz she wakes up like [ __ ] sit
sometimes you go to sleep well sometimes
I'm writing and I lose track of time he
falls asleep and that fall asleep in my
office and then I wake up and it's like
6:00 and then I just go up to bed and
wake you up when he lays down oh not
really
yeah I sleep like crazy boy and she's
got cats all over her entire body while
she's sleeping like Joe why I wish my
cats would want to sleep with me they
don't sleep with you oh I've never not
slept with that I like sleeping up
either at the foot of the bed or on top
of my head where the pillow is but they
tend to just scratch a lot all right
like they'll eat the plants that are by
the headboard so I had always kicked him
out franklin's always cuddled facing me
with his nose against my face and what
and Joseph like the foot of the bed like
always ready to leave if he has to yeah
he's like guarding but yeah that's like
Maddie
your son I'd want a ten-year-old to
sleep on my feet get another cat get
another cat he's so hot we never like
what kind of blow yeah he's so hot - hot
he's homeless [ __ ]
Casey so hyung got a huge dick how you
slide into Dan's without looking like a
creep first of all don't comment on a
person's appearance I wish when you
first like I'm like damn girl you [ __ ]
it that's instant like shut up exactly
it's like hate that we ignored that's
true that sounds weird that's her next
thing is I don't mind no that I learned
my lesson in the myspace days it's cuz
all the kids I grew up with in San Diego
like the dudes were like yo dude I'm
like the [ __ ] master of [ __ ] bro
like those guys they honestly think that
that should work
because they'll shoot their shot about
400 times you know one person will like
yeah they're like one girl that's like
okay fine yeah
all right so another thing is look for
commonalities on their social media like
what Joe did you end it
I like Shiva's she looked like she had a
Shiba dog didn't then we [ __ ] weren't
that's the math we got like you didn't
you didn't slip into her dance being
like hey sexy like a you're thought I
would have if I was fourteen he's not
thirsty you can old man is you're on dr.
Phil and you're like I like Sheba's and
she like Shiva's and then we [ __ ] and
no I mean it's like my god
let me show tell you something here
Tiffany he's got a problem and you need
to fix it the best another thing is make
sure to keep it real because people can
see right through the vet the mask the
badge the mess sent text like you know
very generic like hey you know what no
matter what whether I'm trying to [ __ ]
or not or be a friend always look for
something common because you don't know
if this is gonna be your friend in hobby
or someone that's gonna suck your dick
that's a really good point yeah have you
ever talked to a girl on Instagram and
then when you met them in person
completely different the way they look
not Instagram I got lucky you did like
that yeah we've got we know a couple
folks like that
oh that they are like that maybe do that
on Instagram individual only models like
their personality oh yeah like their
personality on this scram is like on
point and then you meet them in person
it's like you are the most boringest
[ __ ] person I've ever met in my
[ __ ] life I recently met this model
like she's like a legit model well you
know about this
he said you never know who's gonna be
sucking his dick
I told you the story I like when you met
I like to think we met Bart he was like
I don't know if this guy is gonna be my
friend or it's like my big but I'm
whatever roll of the dice that's true
you don't know I mean it's a mystery you
don't any ok with that but anyway you
know about this model story ok so like
my friends very famous photographer he
knows a lot of very professional like
legitimate I'm not talking about
Instagram models I'm talking about the
fringe it omit models yes
runway all that [ __ ] right so you know I
meet her and I go she got a lot Bandra
some random you know but it's different
when I'm looking at it he's not runway
model that's his boy shirt I'm not hot
it's ok you know like it's it's okay I
have dandruff so it's like her job to be
hot and then she [ __ ] up mess and then
Joe would see her at a Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show and he'd sit in the
audience and and like they're running
walking the runway and and he's like
he's like you see that [ __ ] behind her
you think that's not snow
that's not confetti baby that's [ __ ]
dandruff her face was dry [ __ ] narrow
it was so nasty you know she look like
she showered for days when girls are
gonna be taking pictures of or on camera
you know that they put makeup on for
camera just because like you know and
she smelled like [ __ ] sage and buck
and body odor
wait sage is good but not body odor it's
like a hippie that doesn't shower it
tries to hide it she's all natural you
know that's one of them that's Mandy's
favorite smell stop shaming her no it's
not I don't think he's shaming I'm not
saying it's like it's so interesting the
contrast the difference of what somebody
looks like what they can do on an
Instagram or whatever profile or even
photo you know it's it's not a basis of
reality
I'm not trying to talk [ __ ] I'm just
trying to say that there is a difference
like like one is she's a great artist
yeah we are describing the difference
was like she's disgusting because she
was trying to personally attack anybody
I know I know I'm disgusting
okay thank you total sense to me my
friend all I'm trying to say is this
person is the epitome of beauty a lot of
women probably just don't know how to
listen okay I'm just trying to find
something Joe's wearing a suicide vest
she keeps watching it all I'm saying is
don't be jealous because people are
uglier than you seem perfect now you've
insulted everyone that was a perfect Hey
feels greener by yourself
people are uglier in the real world
[Music]